to the day with thank you so much okay
my talk today is about exploiting some
amount of public data to boost the
performance of the private learning
algorithm and to circumvent some of the
existing limitations in differentially
private law the first part of this talk
is going to be based on and perhaps the
larger part is going to be based on
joint work with um Tucker and a
predictor Corte that appeared in
Europe's 2018 and in the later part I'm
going to present some recent
improvements that I have together with
my graduate students and permanentiy
okay so in this work we focus on
classification problems rather than
regression and we aim to achieve two
main goals the first goal is to devise a
framework for privacy for serving
predictions for a mind classification
crease so what do I mean by that
imagine a scenario where we have a
sensitive and a private training set
that is comprised of you know a bunch of
labeled example that come from unknown
distribution and now suppose we have our
sequence of online unlabeled feature
vectors that come one at a time and the
goal here is to design a private
algorithm which I'm gonna call a proof
that uses sensitive training set in
order to provide predictions in terms in
terms of labels for these unlabeled
feature vectors wanted to die and here
I'm actually making the sort of amalah
standard assumption that those unlabeled
feature vectors come from the same model
distribution as the feature vectors in
the trainings
and of course the main requirement here
is that we want these outlet labels are
to abide by the privacy or to protect
the privacy of the sensitive training
set in the sense of differential privacy
which I'm going to more precise about in
a few slides and of course we also want
these labels to be as accurate
predictions as possible
one particular actually design
requirement we also try to impose here
in that we want to wrap our private
algorithm apron around any generic non
private learning algorithm in other
words we want a proof to have only black
box access to any existing non private
learning algorithm and of course in
addition to the obvious advantage that
this would basically you know allow us
to use existing infrastructures of
learning algorithm that are usually
designed without the privacy problem in
mind it will also sort of make our you
know eventually we'll make our framework
model independent or model agnostic
because basically we don't have to care
really about the model class we're
dealing with or the learning problem
we're dealing with as long as we have
access to a good non private learning
algorithm for the same problem so this
is a premise we have access to a good
non private
the second goal and we can think of the
second goal actually has a second phase
for this framework and in this in this
page you make the following assumption
now suppose that these feature vectors
that represent the queries are public
information so they do not entail any
privacy concerns then in in this case
the natural thing to do is to basically
after answering enough queries we can
use the newly label data set as it as a
new training set and feed it to again
any existing non private learning
algorithm and finally out to the
classifier and if actually these labels
are kind of generated in a
differentiated private manner then by
post-processing property of differential
privacy we are fine this final
classifier would be safe to publish and
can be used to answer unlimited number
of future please of course this idea is
not new it's know known as knowledge
transfer and basically what we the only
difference here is that we do that in a
private fashion and even in the privacy
context there has been other works that
consider this framework paradigm of
knowledge transfer where you use a new
training set to Train any good algorithm
and finally output the classifier I'll
talk about that in a few slides
so
of course I guess this slide is
completely unnecessary for this kind of
crowd its kind of workshop but what I
wanted to emphasize mainly here is that
the fact that we use a standard notion
of epsilon Delta differential privacy in
this
okay one legitimate question would be
okay why do we need to go through this
like two-phase approach when we first
answer online queries classification
queries and then construct a new
training set and use kind of any kind on
the Shelf of the Shelf learning
algorithm to finally outfit classifier
why don't we just go to the
straightforward standard approach of
differentially private learning where we
have a simply since the training set you
can instruct and epsilon-delta
differentiate the private learning
algorithm that runs over the sensitive
training set and usually this algorithm
is given a sort of a description for a
predefined model class or hip-hop's
class which I call edge and output some
classifier here which would be safe to
publish because this algorithm is
differentiated right this all this plus
way can be used to you know answer all
our classification quiz well the issue
is that there are certain certain
limitations with this approach first of
all it usually requires designing new
algorithms new private algorithms from
the scratch or at least requires some
you know non-trivial white box
modification for the existing
non-private algorithms and also what is
perhaps kind of more crucial is that
usually the design of such private
algorithms require you know knowledge
about the structure of the model class
or the structure of the learning problem
would be needed so in a sense they are
usually model dependent or problem
dependent the other issue is that in
many cases we already have lower bounds
that show that the accuracy or the
sample complexity of private learners or
learning algorithm in in the context of
the standard approach has necessary
dependency on some you know nasty
parameters like for example the size of
the model class or the domain size
even for simple learning problems like
learning specials which was actually
sort of a the subject of the one of the
previous talks by amis so one way to
kind of circumvent these limitations is
to try to relax them a little bit and
consider this two-phase approach the
first answer online online
classification queries and then make the
assumption that okay but if this
unlabeled feature vectors we got s
queries are actually public information
so they for example it could be provided
by what we call optin users in the
language of mobile data and in such case
we can make use of this public this
amount of unlabeled public data to kind
of like avoid this kind of limitations
and have also black box design approach
and improve the accuracy of private
learning a lot as we will see in a few
slides
okay let me recap the design
requirements for this framework first we
want to design a private algorithm that
will be able to answer a large number of
classification queries so one of the
main challenges in differential privacy
is the issue of composition is that
basically privacy laws the grades as we
you know perform or statistical tasks
from the scene to the set or answer more
queries so we we want since we want to
be able to answer classification queries
we want to design an algorithm that
makes the most conservative views of the
privacy budget that's one issue in this
specific framework the other requirement
is that we want to provide not only
formal privacy guarantees in terms of
differential privacy but also formal
accuracy grantees in terms of sample
complexity bounds or bounce on the
expected miss classification rate
and the search requirement is to have
this black box design approach basically
want to design we want our algorithm to
be wrapped around any black box
non-private learning algorithm and as I
mentioned earlier that would actually
make our framework model agnostic or
model independent basically move the
burden of the problem on to the
underlying not by the planet compass
specifically this black bought a box
design approach in principle would allow
us to have a formal generic
transformation statement in which we can
say that if we have an accurate non
private learner as an underline learner
then immediately we will have
predictions with compatible accuracy you
want to be able to prove something like
that very generic transformation the
accuracy of the underlying of the non of
the underlying non private learner to
accuracy of our predictions and finally
also the accuracy of the final
classifier which will output in the
second stage after the knowledge
transfer so basically want to say that
the private prediction will inherit the
accuracy of the non private level and
the final classifier here assuming that
these feature vectors are public will
also inherit this the same accuracy
of course there has been a sequence of
really nice previous works that studied
similar or more or less the same sitting
I will not have time unfortunately to go
over the details of these nice results
in this time but our perhaps highlight
the main distinctions between our our
our our work and and these and these two
schools so in a nutshell all the
previous words either considered or
provided constructions that are sort of
white box rather than black box or model
dependent or in some cases they only
analyze the single prediction tasks
rather than a sequence of employees and
in some cases they do not provide any
form of accuracy so in particular the
closest related work to ours is the work
by paper not at all where they develop
this petite frame work and the idea was
again the same idea of like employing
this knowledge transfer at a time in a
private in a private manner it's a nice
paper they actually gave extensive
empirical results but they did not
provide any form of accuracy guarantees
there is also second-order distinctions
including for example that the
algorithmic techniques were using are
quite different from some of the
algorithmic techniques you
so let me state our results the first is
for the first goal of the first phase of
this framework we provide a private
algorithm which we call a prayer that is
different
achieve absent of the differential
privacy and it uses any non private
learning algorithm as a black box
and it can accurately answer much more
queried than previous approaches in
particular it can answer about one over
eight effect or more queries and prior
approaches where a tahir is a
misclassification rate of the underlying
impractical so the more accurate the
underlying non-profit learner is the
more queries we can answer and by
accurately in here I mean that the
accuracy of the predictions are
comparable or more or less the same the
accuracy of the nonprofit
and this not sure does this have like
amazing limiting behavior so if you have
a perfect classifier it will I'll put
all your answers for free you cannot
have perfect classifier assuming like
basically you can I mean if you have if
you can if you can if you can show that
with probability one your classifier is
going to output you know oh it's going
to predict all the labels correctly then
yes you can can get privacy for free you
can you can just get that but basically
in this case it'll be Coniston function
but you know according to like the
standards also learning theory we know
that there is always you know you can
only you can only show that in at least
in the PAC learning setting you can show
that if you have enough samples like
with high probability can and so in
there basically the number of samples in
order to achieve zero prediction error
is infinity because you need something
like one or the VC dimension by eight in
order to the number of samples at least
in order to
so yeah in a nutshell what we wanted to
achieve that is that you know something
that basically transformed or transfer
their the accuracy guarantees of the
Ottoman private learner into something
tangible in the sort of the prediction
that we provide private in the second in
the second phase what we give it like
again we are employers knowledge
transfer paradigm and again like after
enough number of queries of to answer
certain number of public unlabeled data
we can use them as a new training set
and finally train any again black box
number of private learner and get out to
the classifier which is more or less
what is done in previous works like the
petty framework but perhaps a new
contribution here is that would provide
a formal accuracy guarantees in terms of
private sample complexity bounds in the
formal PAC learning model and our bounds
are compatible to the non private the
standard non private bounds in in
particular they are completely
characterized by the VC dimension of the
concept class and when I say really that
recently we improve over the
construction that appeared in Europe's
together with migrant student we show a
modification a very simple modification
of this construction that fixes some
issues with
agnostic learning set
so I'll try by the way related to this
question about Icarus to be more formal
later in the talk about the notions of
accuracy and miss classification Richard
to avoid any confusion but let me first
kind of give you a high-level idea of
the sort of the description of our main
construction April for the online
classification queries and the algorithm
is based on a combination between two
powerful techniques in the literature of
differential privacy mainly subsample an
aggregate technique and it's specific
manifestation as a distance to
instability framework that appeared in a
work by Adam and abra deep 2013 and the
other popular technique is sparse vector
technique
so as will see that the exploiting the
sparse vector technique will allow us to
make this conservative use of the
privacy budget and use the inherent
niceness of the data in order to ensure
that we don't pay for privacy when we
don't need so
the first step of the algorithm is to
split our private training set into kata
joint partitions and here K actually is
really important parameter it has to be
set carefully in order to ensure that we
achieve the target accuracy and also the
target privacy keep the privacy laws in
check but I'm not gonna bug you is like
you know my expressions and sort of you
know low-level details in the stove but
just believe me that this needs to be
set carefully but apart from this once
you have the right choice working we
partition the training set into K to
join chunks and then use each chunk to
train your favorite non-private learning
algorithm and hence we end up with a
collection of K classifiers which I call
a transfer cake and now for each
incoming query each unlabeled feature
vector we obtain the votes of these
classifiers for that teacher vector and
here I'm going to assume that we are
dealing with a binary classification
problem but the this construction can be
easily extended to multi-label
okay so what we do next is we simply
count the number of zeros and count the
number of ones and compute the gap or
the margin between the count of one sin
the count of the years and the intuition
is false like suppose that we want to
study the stability of the majority vote
with respect to the input training set
so intuitively when the smarten is large
then the majority vote is going to be
stable with respect to a few changes in
the input range and hence at least
intuitively we would expect it to be
safe to output the majority vote when
this margin is large enough but of
course this margin is a deterministic
function of the training set so we
cannot just out make the decision based
directly on the margin so we do the
stability test in a differentially
private way which is basically the idea
in the distance to instability framework
by atom and already been 2013 we add
first a little bit of noise to that gap
or this margin and then test whether the
noisy margin is large enough if the
answer is yes we say that the prediction
is stable it's fine to release the
majority vote if now it's unstable
meaning that we're going to pay for
privacy and in this case the output
addendum maybe we output something that
is independent of the data so what is
the best thing in the manner of the data
just randomly okay so so far this is
basically a in any instantiation of the
distance to instability framework so far
I didn't say what's his role of sparse
vector which would come later the idea
here is basically that we can show you
think the noise properties is that if
the margin is already sufficiently large
then it was high probability the apples
for of this procedure is going to be the
majority
so we're always guaranteed to output the
majority vote when the marginal Amish
now so this is you know distance to a
disability framework for a single
prediction now we use here the sparse
vector technique in order to be able to
argue that we can we need only to pay
for privacy when we encounter unstable
with unstable prediction in particular
we can show that by exploiting the
sparse vector technique within the
online version of this algorithm we can
show that insurance on Delta
differential privacy over the entire
sequence of predictions the algorithm
needs to halt
only after encountering K squared about
K square epsilon square unstable
particular we don't pay for the stable
crease in terms of price so let me now
give you sort of all the direct
transformation statement and try to
formally argue that the accuracy of the
underlying from a private learner can be
or should would imply accuracy for the
output predictions so suppose now that
we have the following premise that the
underlying non-private learning
algorithm has missed classification rate
which is bounded by it by which I mean
that for each one of these K classifiers
the expected classification error or the
probability of miss prediction is
bounded by the same suppose this is true
then we can show that the number of miss
classification that our April our
private algorithm makes over M queries
is battle bounded by some constant about
3m8 in other words within this M line
quiz the our misclick our private
misclassification rate is going to be at
most 3 8 so in other words we say this
is a black box transformation for the
misclassification rate of the non
private learner to miss classification
rate for the private predictor so an
item is classification rate would be
transformed to 3/8 and idea of the proof
is actually pretty simple
so merely we use our a very simple
counting argument to show that you know
for all the queries except for at most 3
m 8 bad queries or unstable queries in
all the other queries a significant
majority of the classifiers in the
classifier ensemble will agree and they
will agree on the correct level so not
only would have consistency or consensus
or agreement among the those those
classifiers but they were also agree on
the correctly so we'll have stability
and hence by the distance to instability
framework this mean that we that the
margin will be long and will output the
majority vote but also due to the
accuracy of all the classifiers because
you have no misclassification rate they
will also agree on the correct link so
we will also have accuracy for the
generated prediction in other words we
can say that for all the stable queries
whose whose fraction is roughly 1 minus
8 out of the m queries we will have
right classifications will have a bright
like the correct prediction we will make
correct predictions for the unstable
where is that we don't know and we will
make roughly about a constant factor of
the miss classification rate of the
underlying non-private learner as errors
you are miss classification rate has a
black box depend on K suppose it said K
to be s like yeah definitely I swept all
this under there so let me go back
actually so basically this thing we know
that from the privacy analysis of sparse
vector that this is a sort of the number
of unstable quiz that or that basically
this is a kata you have to stop here
so have to tune the number of like
unstable queries that you'd expect to
this the idea is like when the non
private learner has miss classification
rate eita the number of unstable queries
using this counting argument is going to
be roughly M times ada and hence we have
to tune this to m 8 and this will give
you a setting for K in terms of M the
number of queries you're answering and
in terms of the miss classification
guarantee of the of the admin private
learning yeah it's a black box promise
so I'm gonna for now at least I'm going
to assume that you know we trust this
promise but it doesn't have any so you
know this I just wanted to highlight
this assumption about a table of them is
15 generate of the non private learning
learning learning algorithm does not
have an impact on the privacy guarantee
so we still whatever what we're gonna
stop after then it only impacts accuracy
more data you have perhaps the
classification error is become smaller
and so
function okay right right so yeah
through to true so basically that's true
so in order definitely but we have to
kind of like stick to certain formal
models in order to analyze what is n or
the number of data points that's true
but you're right so you can think of K
as a constant amplification or like a
certain amplification factor for the
sample complexity of the non-private
learners so basically we want to ensure
that each one of these K classifiers are
are accurate so you have to kind of like
multiply everything by K in it for now
you don't have to look at back learning
it's just like a black box premise and
the line not private learning algorithm
has this much classification we're fine
regardless of how we get this I'll talk
about back and agnostic back in
that's a great question so now once we
have this simple transformation
statement we can easily show it's very
obvious that this implies that we can
answer about 1 over 8 and more queries
then approach it that are based directly
on the advanced composition why because
we're only paying for privacy for 8:00
a.m. we're is rather than all the
increase the small biz idea now we can
then move to the next phase of like
knowledge transfer now suppose we answer
enough queries M is sufficiently large
and this feature vectors are public then
we can use this new training set to
train again any amount private learning
algorithm and finally output a
classifier and again we can formally are
a reason about the accuracy of the final
classifier by combining suit two simple
facts the first is that if we assume
that the underlying non-private learner
in a proof is accurate or have lomas
classification rate then a prett will
have no misclassification rate and hence
this training set will inherit this
lomas classification so all the the new
training set s hat will also have lowest
classification and now again if the
external non private learner B he told
us is good learner meaning it would
generate a classifier that I have high
accuracy this then we would expect that
the output classifier of this learner
learning algorithm will have a
misclassification rate that is close to
it to the miss classification date in
its input training set so basically the
final accuracy or the expected miss
classification rate of the final
classifier will be comparable to the
accuracy of the underlying non-private
Monica
well let me try to be more formal in the
last few how much in the last few
minutes and talk about a foreman
analysis for April in the formal PAC
learning model and just to remind us a
distinction between two settings in
impact learning there is a special case
of realized which confer risible case
and the more general agnostic case and
in both cases were given a hypothesis
class or a model class edge and the
difference in the the main difference in
the realizable case is that we make the
assumption that the true labeling
function comes from that type of class
okay so all the feature vectors and
training set are labeled by this edge
star now we say that an algorithm B is
alpha pack learner if given enough
samples it output a classifier H hat
whose expected error on a fresh sample
is bounded by alpha okay and as a
standard result in learning theory we
know that with high probability this can
be achieved as long as n or the number
of samples in the training set is about
the VC dimension of this class by out
where VC dimension is complexity measure
for the last class
okay so the difference in the agnostic
case with emotional case is that if we
we remove the Assumption realizability
assumption that the true labeling
function come from from edge all the
examples can come from any arbitrary
distribution and in this case we say
that an algorithm is alpha agnostic that
learner if given again enough samples it
output a classifier such that their
expected
true error or the true error of by H hat
on a fresh sample from the distribution
is bounded by alpha plus gamma and here
gamma is something out of our control
basically it's approximation error or
the minimum possible error that can be
achieved by any hypothesis in my class
and again stain the result in learning
theory is that with n about VC dimension
by alpha squared we can always achieve
alpha agnostic background but what I
wanted to kind of like clarify here we
emphasize here is that alpha we can
control basically we cannot make alpha
arbitrary small as long as we increase
sample size but gamma in the agnostic
case we can't it's constant it depends
really on the class we have so now
applying this genic transformation
result in the PAC learning model let's
first start with the realizable case so
assume assuming that the underlying
non-private learner is alpha pack
learner for the model class then a prig
would inherit this and we will can say
that it that April will have a miss
classification rate bounded by GL so
Coniston
amplification for alpha here is not
significant because we can make it
arbitration by increasing the sample
size in the agnostic case will be some
issue some problem because if we assume
that the underlying non drive private
learner is alpha agnostic back learner
so there is no realizability assumption
then we can only say that a pre will
have a misclassification rate three
alpha plus three gun
now if gamma is small we're fine that's
fine but if gum up like an Al it's not
the same but it's analogous to the base
optimal somehow right so it's not in our
control so if it's gamma is like large
like ten percent or something a constant
amplification by a factor of three is
going to - to make a problem to be
problematic in in John this is an issue
that we have to deal with and for that
reason we kind of like apply we make a
small modification to our construction
in order to actually deal with this
issue and you know get rid of this extra
constant next to the approximation error
so this is a recent vote that's still
unpublished and the idea of this
modification is based on pre-processing
of the training set before feeding it to
a prett to our private predictor and
basically the technique is based on
relabeling the training set so the
training set is not right it's not
realizable okay let's make it reliable
so the idea is to really label the
training set and this relabeling
procedure actually follow exactly the
same as it a beautiful technique that
appeared and work by Amazon and and Kobe
and Orion 2015 called the label label
post technique and basically this would
allow us to reduce agnostic case to the
realizable case and we know that you
know our April can deal with with with
reliable
welcome yes here is basically that this
procedure this pee person step not
always completely fishing but who cares
in agnostic learning we it's usually the
case that we don't have computationally
efficient learning but of course this is
for the proper learning case no no no
that's also that's also something that
it's not exactly Bly its genetic
so you can do the same procedure for any
hypothesis it's not for specific
hypothesis you can still do this P
processing step for any edge but of
course not exactly black box so the
black box part is going to be after this
pre-processing step the only thing also
I want to emphasize here which is a good
point is that this is done once and for
right so we do this pre-processing step
and then you can use it for online
classification all the time online
classification and the in online
classification query space you can stick
to any black box pack learner as an
underlying learning algorithm so so let
me quickly give a brief description of
this nice a nice technique do to be an S
15 and the idea is basically we're gonna
start this is a training sample we're
gonna start with a little bit more
samples than the non-private sample
complexity it's about like one over
epsilon factor more samples and they
were going to do subsampling by epson
fraction and the reason of this is
actually not important for the sake of
the stokke but the reason of the self of
sampling step is to keep the privacy
laws in check at the very end okay so
now let's let's start from the
subsampled
training set the first step we're gonna
do after that is to remove the two
labels and keep them aside okay so we
end up with an unlabeled version of the
training sample and now the side of that
unlabeled version is about the
non-private same
now what we're going to do is like will
generate all the dichotomies that the
hypothesis H can generate on the
unlabeled sample and by Sowers lemma we
know that there is only polynomial
number of dichotomies and each dichotomy
can be represented by some
representative hypothesis in the path so
we end up with a set of Representative
hypotheses which are polynomial is
polynomial in M then whose number is
polynomial in n now what you gonna do
later stop us but like what was in this
paper basically the Ray labeling
procedure is that you apply the
exponential mechanism on the top of this
set in order to select one hypothesis H
hat that approximately has the least
empirical error okay so the score
function is basically would be the
number or the negative of the number of
disagreements with the two labels this
is a skoshe function of the national and
hence basically can think of H hat as
something that will be will have a low
disagreement rate with the erm - the
hypothesis have the least in particular
now that's it you're gonna use this H
hat to real able to say ok and now the
key lemma actually that appeared in
being s well they use this label boost
for a different purpose for the
semi-supervised case learning under
private but this procedure is very
actually powerful because it come up
with like very this very useful lemma so
this relabeling procedure in its own is
not private
there's no differential private however
if you have a differential be profit
algorithm a and then if you look at the
composition of a and this relating
procedure then this composition remains
so basically if you apply differentially
private procedure on the output of this
relabeled procedure the whole thing
would remain absent up to the French
bread so that's a key key point because
we're gonna now use our apron on the top
of that like we will we will compose the
apron algorithm after this relevant
procedure and the entire procedure will
still remain epsilon-delta the French
part the other observation about this
which I already mentioned is that the
relabeling function H hat have low
disagreement rate with the ear my boss
on on the on the training set now this
is like almost the last bite
it was slide before the last okay so I
just wanted to kind of like quickly
describe what is going to happen and
that's basically we're going to use this
reliable and procedure to really label
the sample and now we have to do
something that is basically to ensure
that the input to April is ID so what we
do is like sample the same amount of
examples from s hat and feed it to
approved and now that's it we're gonna
use a probe to generate the private
label for the online course and here's
something that I didn't mention is that
we start again with a little bit more
sample for example than the previous
slide so there is an you know an
expansion factor here Rho that really
depends on the number of queries you
want to answer them so one thing
actually in the analysis that we need to
be careful about is that given the sort
of the you know the guarantees we have
from this real label procedure and also
because we here sample from the
empirical distribution but we can only
shop at that point but what is obvious
is that the empirical disagreement rate
between a proof our algorithm viewed as
a classifier
and the ERM hypothesis the underlying
Aryan hypothesis is low but this is only
the empirical disagreement meaning that
apron will have low training error on
the original training set well this is
not enough of course to argue that the
expected misclassification rate of a
proof on fresh samples going to be low
but okay like empirical disagreement
rate is low would imply that also they
expected disagreement is low using a
simple unit for convergence aren't so
you can show easily that if this is low
then the expected disagreement between a
probe and erm hypothesis also going to
be low and hence we're back to the
realizable case now our reference
hypothesis is a hypothesis which comes
from the class from the high post class
so it's reliable and we can go from
there
so we label everything like a probe as
if this is our H star and eventually
because the erm hypothesis has good miss
constrain
according like based on standard results
in learning theory the air in my
processes achieve alpha agnostic tack
learning so it has a good expected miss
classification rate then we can easily
show that a prevalent heard that and the
final muscular fication rate of April in
expectation will be all alpha plus K so
we kind of like get rid of the extra
three or the constant factor next to the
approximation error and again we can use
this in the knowledge transfer setting
where we wait until we answer about my
queries where M here is a non private
agnostic central complexity and then we
use the newly labeled set as a training
set feed it to any auto shop agnostic
pack learner and finally output a
classifier H final and using the same
line of analysis we can show that the
expected miss classification rate or
expected error of of this hypothesis is
going to be over four plus nine
and what's interesting here is that the
associated private sample complexity
which is the end we have to start with
in order to finally output a classifier
here in this two-phase procedure that
have such error guarantee is that this
expression okay so if you look at the
sample complex you can see that if
epsilon is a constant and if alpha the
excess risk is less than one of the over
the VC dimension then basically you
don't pay for price like it's the same
as a non private sample complexity in
this case so if alpha is small and is a
constant that's it so I'm just gonna sum
up quickly in this work we consider this
two-phase approach where first we
provide a privacy predict that
preserving predictor that can answer a
large number of classification queries
and it uses any existing nonprofit
algorithm is a black box and the
accuracy guarantee is really based on
the premise that the underlying on
private learner is has good accuracy in
some cases to impose okay good accuracy
constraint on the underlying on private
learner perhaps we have to make to relax
this black box statement a little bit
but in general this generic
transformation holds as long as the non
private learner is good and in the
second phase we do the knowledge
transfer and finally show poor mo
private sample complexity bound and give
a modification for the construction to
deal with agnostic thank you
[Applause]
so if I understand that the idea of the
proof correctly all you need is supposed
to have a different split and the the
train classifier although they are not
getting the fair accuracy so not say are
wrong and they're running the same way
as far as they agree with each other
affect you in terms of this this black
box prediction right as well as long as
here you're talking about the accuracy
can interior the privacy so the privacy
is always I'm talking about actors the
inaccuracy yes did you an alternative
way of getting this this independence on
on this gamma kind agnostic suppose are
all your pacifiers are stable suppose
for every given data points the kind of
prediction that they're gonna make
mistakes on they're gonna make the
mistake I'm the same in the same way
sure if this is a case we can look like
an agnostic learning we cannot ensure
this over time actually they could be
highly you know inconsistent that's like
suppose it is really yours if you have
stability another another you know you
know independent assumption of stability
then you can maybe pull off something
like it could be an assumption but it
also could be some
you can show in in the algorithm yes
with specific but now it says you have
to you know this construction will have
to be algorithmic dependent somehow you
have to kind of like you know impose
stability in the way you designed I'm
just saying that this could sure
I mean well in agnostic case we don't
know that that but like if we go for
regression problems or continuous
learning or something like surrogate
loss of course you can apply these ideas
and you stability to to impose this
consistently generic attack learn and
private learning dependence on the size
of the concept is that coming out no no
it's only completely because we make
aware make relaxation here that the
feature vectors are public the online
queries are unlabeled feature vectors
and they are public there is no we only
protect the original training set and
that that is a relaxation definitely
okay so and hence we can show that we
can give sample complexity bound that
only depends on the V Spanish by the way
I need to make also which I didn't say
forgave me about that this thing has
also been considered in previous works
by I think a common iike and Daniel su
and also Kobe and Orion des amis
in a setting that is kind of like also
related to this will the only consider a
scenario where the labels only are
private but in the training set but the
feature vectors are not so you can see
you can see that basically any algorithm
for the setting I showed here can be
used to kind of like tackle or deal with
this privately label setting but also
interestingly in their work the
construction that they use more or less
can be used also in the constrained in
the settings where you have public
feature vectors and private training set
completely
like the labels in the future of actual
private but separate set with his
unlabeled data that are public their
construct but their construction as I
mentioned before was like the tape in
2015 was was and correct me if I'm wrong
was white box so they use experimental
and then you can show kind of in this
case you can show also bounds that
depends on only on the visa management
one distinction also between our work
and the previous work is that we
consider on by queries certain most of
the construction the previous work look
at that setting where you have all the
public data unlabeled data at hand and
then you can use it to construct an
alpha net or something and then run the
exponential mechanism on the top society
but in our case we kind of like impose
that the queries coming online fashion
you have to respond with labels before
you kind of used the new training set
does okay so you've been assuming that
you have a collection of unlabeled data
have you given thought to how you could
generate sent collection without having
it ahead of time you generated yes from
what that's what I'm asking yeah that's
like completely impossible and I just
don't know it or is this hard like
randomly gets well well so no no but
like here's the thing so what this bone
is down to at least in the batch case if
you have public unlabeled data is its
equivalent to learning or knowing the
Marshall distribution okay so what what
is more or less you can imagine is like
if you have enough public unlabeled data
you can use them to you know learn the
marginal distribution on the features
and then once you learn the marginal
distribution actually private learning
the companies because you can create
them so I guess maybe your question is
like what if we have some partial
information about the marginal
distribution right so you know some some
prior for example about the margin
speech yeah I think this is an
interesting question and we kind of
currently working on something
let's it's late hey what do you think
marginal distribution you mean he acts
like the distribution of the features
yeah
you can't give me it don't have some
individuals marginals for every border
I don't just the whole thing on the
whole feature vector alright so it's
sort of like a sitting where you sort of
known know the distribution right but
yeah well no but yes I know because here
here you don't see the entire in order
to know the distribution the obvious
thing to do you need VEC over alpha
squared public unless but here we import
the search of the constrain you have to
it's online so I have to respond with a
private label so you don't have if you
have them before and that much samples
beforehand yes
becomes more or less you know you can
create and have some net at least you
know information theoretically you can
do this another answer that has appeared
in previous work like such as is that
often you have opt-in users like Firefox
users right agree right exactly exactly
have a weaker privacy guarantee true
actually I had a slice for an example
but I just remove them omitted them
about that right before just before the
talk so in cases where you have you know
user with with no privacy concerns then
you can use such data
[Applause]